come at the hour returneth the players
Manchester City's troublemakers arriving
home after Triumph in Istanbul
in their wake some of the 20 000 fans
had flown out to really was incredible
including three generations of the
Livingston family
for over 70 years
do you think you'd ever see this in your
lifetime no
not at all so he's lucky your grandsons
scored obviously in the second half so
we oh yeah
balling our eyes out it was absolutely
phenomenal absolutely phenomenal will
you be able to get to the parade
exam tomorrow morning
it's worth it
it was a euphoric moment too for fans
who hadn't made it to Turkey and watched
on big screens
or in pubs across the city it's
significant wasn't it
the blues Triumph brings Manchester's
two great rival teams on par master
united the Reds the only other team to
secure the treble back in 1999. I'm a
son he said that Manchester is purple
today so because only two teams in the
country have actually done the trouble
and it's both Manchester teams he said
so the Manchester is purple today but
who do you think now people will say is
the better team oh yeah cool cool man
that's a tough question
[Music]
this city will celebrate tomorrow as the
team holds a huge parade through
Manchester Catherine Liberty Sky News
Manchester